don't you love it the first game you
play and you got them mr. Wiggles ok so
I'm simply doing my mind now revised
strategy against him just play quickly
very quickly and just don't mind the
simplifications ok it's a bit strange I
mean I'm not not bad for black but kind
of uncommon what he plays but i'm not
spending any time as it will be a click
fest in the end game anyway many people
are recommended to me i should play more
aggressively and try to yeah get him in
in complicated positions i have tried
that and somehow i never worked so now
i'm just trying what I said yeah play
the simple game that he doesn't place
and just can't lay those stupid end
games when nothing ever happens and just
be quick about it if I get a draw I mean
I'm it's like 200 points I'd adria
mysteriously rated higher mysteriously
so I'll just play a draw why not I
really don't understand how you how one
can play this kind of strategy it's
really weird
I'm just quicker now they are now in
this game important is not to spend any
time pretty not just just play because
it's absolutely doing nothing it just is
a mistake to spend any time you know
it's entirely pointless but it's the
game Jackie chooses to play in 40
seconds I'm by the way when do I need to
play a pawn move to avoid the draw move
33 was the last poor move so wrong move
80 I need to play upon
game drawn are we got a repetition yeah
he just gave me aids aid rating points
it's completely pointless as I know but
it's a way to gain points you just play
one of those super boring useless
positions and get eight points the the
text never worked against him so I just
play his game and then take drawers
whatever in recent games it was kind of
okay I didn't didn't lose I only lost
when I tried something fancy yeah not
much to analyze this is a a line where
this idea is well known and it leads to
a position where yeah why does white
should be slightly better but he
equalised it effortlessly yeah probably
Here I am probably I need to do
something more a little bit more
ambitious but well I simply played this
game oh I completely planned to play a
game like that with them and just and
just take that wrong way it's it's not
exciting yeah it's good well what can
you do so I'll take some points and
that's it thanks for watching